IT'S "THE FIVE"
IT'S "THE FIVE."
SO, AS THE POSTGAME ANALYSIS
CONTINUES, WE REALIZE THAT FOR
TRUMP'S CRITICS, PEACE MEANS
DEFEAT.
I MEAN, IF YOU LISTEN TO THE
MEDIA RIGHT NOW, IT'S LIKE WE
KILLED ELVIS.
>> WHEN PRINCESS DIANA DIED, FOR
EXAMPLE, THERE WAS A HUGE
EMOTIONAL OUTPOURING.
IT TURNS OUT THAT THIS GENERALLY
IS A BELOVED HERO OF THE
IRANIAN --
WOULD GET PICTURES UP NOW.
THESE ENORMOUS CROWDS COMING
OUT.
THERE IS NO AMERICAN EMOTION IN
THIS CASE, BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
EMOTION ON THE OTHER SIDE.
>> Greg: I'M ALMOST IMPRESSED
BY HIS STUPIDITY.
YOU'VE BEEN AROUND.
THEY WILL SHOUT DEATH TO AMERICA
OVER ANYTHING, INCLUDING ONE HBO
CANCELS.
I GUESS WE BETTER NOT KILL ANY
BAD GUYS THEN.
WITH THAT LOGIC, WE SHOULD HAVE
STAYED OUT OF WORLD WAR II AND
FREED EVERYONE FROM DEATH ROW.
BUT IN THE MEDIA'S WORLD, TRUMP
IS HITLER.
>> WHAT YOU ARE DESCRIBING
FEELS LIKE THE SORT OF UNIFIED
NATIONAL OUTPOURING THAT IS
RESERVED FOR A SMALL NUMBER OF
FIGURES FOR ANYONE.
I MEAN, A BELOVED PRESIDENT.
>> Greg: WHAT A --
REMEMBER WHEN THEY BASHED TRUMP
FOR BEING MEAN TO MS-13?
NOW, HE'S GOT "THE VIEW"
APPLAUDING WHITE RACISTS,
BECAUSE THEY AGREE WITH "THE
VIEW."
>> REMEMBER RICHARD SPENCER?
>> LUNATIC.
>> THE WHITE NATIONALIST GROUP?
NOT ANYMORE.
HE TWEETED LAST NIGHT, "I DEEPLY
REGRET VOTING FOR AND PROMOTING
DONALD TRUMP IN 2016."
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> WOW.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THAT'S INTERESTING.
>> Greg: SHE ALMOST SAID
THAT'S GOOD NEWS AND SHE CAUGHT
HERSELF.
>> I SPOKE TO SECRETARY GENERAL
YESTERDAY AND WE HAD A GREAT
CONVERSATION.
HE WAS VERY, I THINK HE WAS
ACTUALLY EXCITED.
AND ACTUALLY HAD A NAME.
NATO, RIGHT, AND THEN YOU HAVE
ME, MIDDLE EAST.
I SAID, WHAT A BEAUTIFUL NAME.
I'M GOOD AT NAMES.
>> Greg: WE DON'T DESERVE HIM.
MEANWHILE, MAYOR PETE SAYS THAT
MAYBE WE SHOULD SHARE THE BLAME,
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS IRAN WHO DID
THE SHOOTING.
TRUMP ONCE AGAIN BOILS HIS
CRITICS, NOT JUST BY BEING
RIGHT, BUT LETTING THEM BE SO
WRONG.
CHECK OUT THE CNN INTERVIEW.
>> THE AMERICAN GOVERNMENT, THE
AMERICAN PRESIDENT, MADE A
SERIOUS MISCALCULATION.
THEY MADE A SERIOUS MISTAKE BY
ASSASSINATING, BY TAKING THIS
TERRORIST ACTION AGAINST
QASEM SOLEIMANI, AND I'M SURE
THAT THEY REGRET WHAT THEY'VE
DONE.
>> Greg: DOES THAT LADY LOOK
FAMILIAR TO YOU?
>> YOU SAID IN THE PRESS
CONFERENCE THE OTHER DAY, YOU
SAID THE OTHER DAY, THAT IF
THERE WAS AN ATTACK ON THIS
EMBASSY, YOU WOULD ATTACK THE
HOSTAGES.
DO YOU MEAN THAT?
>> YES, WE MEAN IT.
>> WOULD YOU PERSONALLY LIFT UP
A GUN, PUT IT TO THE HEAD OF ONE
OF THESE PEOPLE AND KILL THEM?
>> YES.
WHEN I SEE IT KILLING MY SISTERS
AND BROTHERS IN THE STREETS, OF
COURSE.
OPPRESSION AND TYRANNY MUST BE
DESTROYED.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, I'M
THINKING, MAYBE DON'T GET AN
OPINION ON AMERICA FOR SOMEONE
WHO THREATENED TO KILL AMERICAN
HOSTAGES.
BUT THEY'VE GOT TO FIND ONE
PERSON OUTSIDE THEIR OWN NEWS
ROOM.
THAT'S HARD, BECAUSE THAT ONE
PERSON, QASEM SOLEIMANI, IS DEA
DEAD.
SO, MARTHA, I WANT TO GO TO TOO
ABOUT THE PLANE.
WE ARE LEARNING THAT IT WAS
PROBABLY OR LIKELY SHOT DOWN BY
IRAN.
PETE TRUDEAU, SAYS THAT IT IS
TIT-FOR-TAT OF MILITARY POWERS,
ESSENTIALLY SPREADING THE BLAME.
>> Martha: I MEAN, THE
SUGGESTION THAT THERE IS BLAME
FOR THE 176 INDIVIDUALS WHO
PERISHED IN THIS PLANE CRASH, I
THINK IS REALLY A REMARKABLE,
REMARKABLE STATEMENT ON BEHALF
OF SOMEONE WHO IS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
DO NOT UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
MISSILE, FROM WHAT WE ARE
LEARNING, WAS SENT OUT BY
IRANIANS.
IT WAS RUSSIAN-MADE.
IT WAS A NAME IN THEIR OWN
EFFORT TO RETALIATE, WHICH THEY
SAID THEY WANTED TO DO.
BUT DO NOT GO A STEP FURTHER
BACK TO TALK ABOUT THE KILLING
OF AMERICAN CONTRACTORS.
TO TALK ABOUT THE ATTEMPTED
OVERRUN OF THE U.S. EMBASSY,
SOVEREIGN TERRITORY IN IRAQ,
THAT WAS BUILT BY THE
UNITED STATES.
I JUST THINK IT'S AN
IRRESPONSIBLE STATEMENT BY A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
>> Greg: YET, I DON'T THINK IT
HELPED HIM.
LAWRENCE, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THIS?
>> YEAH, I THINK IT'S A
COMPLICATED MATTER, BUT I THINK
THERE ARE TWO CAMPS.
LOOK, I WENT IN THERE YESTERDAY
TO TALK TO THE GENERAL AND THE
BRIEFER'S ABOUT NOT THE ATTACKS
COME ABOUT AUTHORIZATION.
ONE THAT YOU THINK YOU NEED TO
COME BACK TO CONGRESS TO DECLARE
WAR?
HE AGREES WITH THE KILLING OF
SOLEIMANI.
AS A MATTER OF A FACT, IF YOU
DON'T BELIEVE IT, GO BACK TO THE
DOCUMENTS THAT CONGRESS SIGNED
BACK IN 2002, THAT GAVE THE
PRESIDENT THE CALL TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN.
HE HAS 48 HOURS TO NOTIFY
CONGRESS.
WE DON'T EVEN HAVE TO DEBATE
THIS.
WHAT HE IS SAYING AS THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN MOMENTS WHERE THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY IS
MISLED.
WE JUST SAW REPORTS ON
AFGHANISTAN.
WE NEED TO KNOW EVERYTHING
BEFORE WE DECIDE TO GO TO WAR.
CONGRESS DOES HAVE THE RIGHT TO
DO THIS.
>> Martha: THE RESOLUTION, IS
REALLY NONBINDING.
IT'S MORE OF A STATEMENT THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO BE
BEHOLDEN TO.
BUT I WANT TO GO TO THE MEDIA.
THEY ARE MAKING THIS FALSE MORAL
EQUIVALENCY BETWEEN THE IRANIAN
REGIME AND PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP, A.K.A., AMERICA
AND WHAT WE ARE DOING TO PROTECT
AMERICANS IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
FOR HIM TO SAY THAT WE HAVE JUST
AS MUCH RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS
PLANE SHOOT DOWN AS THE IRANIANS
DID, COMPLETELY ELIMINATES ANY
KIND OF RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT.
THEY ARE HIDING THE BLACK BOXES.
THEY DON'T WANT US TO FIND OUT
WHAT HAPPENED, AND ALSO, IT'S
REALLY INTERESTING TO SEE THE
MEDIA CONSTANTLY SAY THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS A BIGOT, THE
PRESIDENT IS ANTI-GAY, THE
PRESIDENT DOES THIS.
NOW, THEY ARE OPENLY DEFENDING
PEOPLE LIKE SOLEIMANI.
THEY STONE WOMEN, THEY HANG AND
JUSTIFY IT JUST THE OTHER DAY.
THEY KILL INNOCENT PROTESTERS IN
THE STREETS FOR DARING TO SPEAK
OUT AND NOT SHOW UP TO
SOLEIMANI'S FUNERAL.
YOU CAN'T JUST BE AGAINST THIS
TYPE OF BEHAVIOR WHEN YOU THINK
IT'S COMING FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND THEN TURN AROUND AND DEFEND
THE IRANIAN REGIME.
>> Greg: WE'VE RUN OUT OF
TIME.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THIS IS A STUPID WAR.
>> Greg: IT'S NOT A WAR.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S FRIENDS HAVE
HAD THE GUTS TO TELL HIM.
KILLING SOLEIMANI WAS A TERRIBLE
IDEA.
BRILLIANTLY EXECUTED.
WHY ARE WE --
LET ME FINISH.
WHY ARE WE PICKING THIS FIGHT?
FOR WHAT?
WE ASSASSINATED HIM.
WHY DID WE DO THAT?
LISTEN, I'VE GOT NEWS FOR YOU,
THEY SAY HE KILLED 600
AMERICANS, THE LAST TIME I
COUNTED, THERE WERE 600,000
IRAQIS WHO HAD BEEN KILLED.
I'M SICK OF THIS WAR.
>> Greg: ME TOO.
>> AND NOW WE ARE PICKING A
FIGHT WITH THE OTHER PEOPLE, THE
WRONG --
>> Greg: YOU ARE CONFLATING
TWO THINGS.
I AGREE WITH YOU ABOUT THE IRAQ
WAR.
>> Geraldo: AT WHAT POINT DO
WE SAY ENOUGH ALREADY?
>> Greg: I AGREE.
I AGREE WITH YOU ON THAT.
BUT THIS IS DIFFERENT.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT WAR.
YOU ARE IN A PRISON OF TWO
IDEAS.
NO OR NO WAR.
THIS WAS AN EXECUTIVE ACTION.
>> Geraldo: WE HAVE ALREADY
RETALIATED.
THIS STARTED WHEN THE MILITIA
KILLED AN AMERICAN CONTRACTOR
AND WOUNDED SEVERAL OTHERS.
>> Martha: AN ATTACK ON THE
AMERICAN EMBASSY.
>> Geraldo: YOU ARE MISSING A
KEY THING THAT HAPPENED.
THEY KILLED THE AMERICAN
CONTRACTOR, WOUNDED THE OTHERS.
WE HAVE A MASSIVE RETALIATION
AGAINST THE SAME MILITIA IN
SYRIA AND IN IRAQ.
WE KILLED 25 IRAQIS.
THEY KILLED THE CONTRACTOR.
THEN THEY HAD THE DEMONSTRATION
AND THE UPRISING, THE SIEGE OF
THE EMBASSY.
THIS WAS ACTION, REACTION.
>> Martha: WE TOOK OUT THE
HEAD OF THE SNAKE OF THE LARGEST
TERRORIST ORGANIZATION IN THE
WORLD.
>> Greg: NO, YOU'RE RIGHT.
BUT THAT'S THE MIDDLE EAST RIGHT
NOW.